this is the shit so it starts off like
something lay men on the moon years ago
and Buzz Aldrin your Armstrong had to go
up there see what it is it's one small
step for man one giant leap for more
than meets the eye
hey excuse me one moment thank you
apparently I'm being sued Court will
come to order
Your Honor ladies and gentlemen of the
jury Murray please I think we all know
how my reviews go and then clearly this
charlatan is stealing from that now I
may be an old-fashioned bum but in my
day when somebody was stealing something
it was in the best nature to make that
bastard pay
oh come on the transformer review was
one of the first reviews I ever did I
was still discovering my identity I
think the kind of review every time a
transformer movie comes out it's
tradition you saw me mumbling that
review to myself on the street and
decided to steal it yeah I finally gave
you a job doing all those reviews
tonight sure our styles were similar
back then but as time went on I
discovered that I was much more
comfortable ripping off Lewis Black need
I remind you that you have not done a
traditional nostalgia critic review in
weeks even this toy room scenario it's
just a clever way for you to be lazy
hey these green screens are hard don't
change the subject anyway need I remind
you that I did an old versus new a True
Grit recently those don't count anyway
everybody stopped listening to you after
you said the new karate kid was better
than the old hey that wasn't even
payable Rita's accent neat I also remind
you that this is not the first time you
broke in your word you guaranteed me
that our search for the Necronomicon was
never gonna be filled by anybody hey hey
I have been shown that footage to a soul
except for parties get-togethers and the
most probable DVD extra yes oh my gosh
my my not my first order mr. Baum would
you care to act out how you would have
done the review of transformers three
city and bedtime please
hmm yeah I didn't agree these movie I've
ever seen in my life
boys it meets the spoilers the excess
moon landing they happened many years
ago objection your honor nobody said he
could use jump cuts in this Court
I even sure how he's doing in real time
anyway overruled
hey that happened many years ago and
apparently happen because of Transformer
landed on there I didn't know that I
thought we always went up for its cheese
after all with the perception s what is
inclement but no we went up there to get
a transformer but then we compared to
Sam week in Week eight who has a new
girlfriend you know because the other
one called the director Hitler this
seems kind of rude all he does is blow
stuff up and kill people telling the
most beautiful survive and apparently
she didn't like posing like a whore
idiot but luckily the British do so
Ricky Ricky's going out with this
British girlfriend who may or may not be
dating the schmuck from enchanted by
that doesn't matter he's looking for a
job but he doesn't why did you find a
job fight on brother he has much more
realistic goals in mind like fighting
with transformers in an intergalactic
battle I fought with transformers in an
intergalactic battle once we made potato
head pay but wiki we he decides he's
gonna get his way oh by streaming every
other line I'm suppose I realize another
da la la hey keep the easy annex outing
like a simpleton down would ya that's
for the audience to do - eternal
optimist brings the Sentinel back to
life and he's like we have to find these
pillars in order to bring Cybertron back
I thought Cybertron kinda sorta was
destroyed he kinda sorta is but there's
also kind of sort of transformers in the
moon in the moon kinda sorta why they're
a bunch of transformer stuck in the moon
don't touch me I have facial hair okay
bitch
but then Optimus is like wait why would
I want to do this Oh cuz I'm betraying
you well that's kinda sorta bad kinda
sort of day so then the Sentinels
working for Megatron and the both of
them are like get rid of the Autobots
are we were destroy the earth and what
if we go then we will destroy the earth
oh yeah kind of is Dipper yeah so the
people of Earth send the Autobots in a
rocket because I'm sure evil robots that
took over a planet before and we are now
getting rid of the only thing that can
stop them can totally be trusted
so they launch the Autobots into the air
but then the decepticons Bellomo so then
the Decepticons start blowing up a whole
big chunk of the earth and they plan to
make mankind their slaves I was a slave
once but that's a boring story
so answers off a trip from enchanted is
actually working within to septa cons I
guess they can call that a detective con
job
well it turns out the Autobots weren't
really destroyed
we're not really destroyed but watching
the Rockies kind of sorta
I mean did the people see you can
underline kinda sorta any what was there
like a bunker that nobody saw you sneak
into and then they just launched their
thing not knowing that nothing was on
trying to sort uyc shit off yes sir then
shot it boom boom boom boom bullets are
flying explosions are happening and
buildings are falling apart it Michael
Bay is really broadening his rise and
that he's putting more broads in it
but then this giant mechanical tapeworm
starts circling the building and our
hero start falling out ah but then the
Autobots seen them Jessa Oh what do you
mean oh we came out of nowhere when you
didn't expect it it's a yeah yeah that's
up to 12th time you've done it we're
starting to expect it now oh and
something really weird in the middle of
the action scenes I think the camera
started blinking it was like ah ah ah
Lukie ah that's a really weird thing to
do it's okay we'll play the inception
music to make it look cool of course the
inception music fixes everything kinda
soreness so the Blanchette goes over to
Megatron and she's like dude you should
totally kill sit in it and he's like
okay but Optimus Prime is like it's just
you and me Sentinel boom-boom girl
completely crazy noise destroyed the
movies over oh wait they still make a
charge it's just you and me Megatron
boom boom go clunk hey now the movie is
over oh wait there's always that generic
speech he has to make at the end America
freedom it's good hurry this is just a
repo scene change
you got change I cannot have a guy oh
yeah
can I change and then the music plays
over it I say something witty usually
under five seconds it is the decision of
this court that all overly optimistic
jump cut reviews will be done by Chester
a bum and no one else
all rise and